regardez ces images d'une marche funèbre
ce soir dans les rues de la capitale à
l'appel du collectif village oberkampf
sa mort un beau des centaines de
restaurateurs des films à paris pour
manifester contre les mesures prises par
le gouvernement je vous propose
d'écouter l'une des organisatrices alors
pourquoi cette action on avait envie
hein symboliquement de montrer que l'art
est en train de filer notre restauration
qu'on est par terre qu'on est con et
stigmatisé on comprend on comprend tout
ce sont les mots que prend les mesures
sanitaires qu'on nous demande on les a
respectés
depuis le début on est pas on se pose
pas la fermeture des bars ici on nous
dit que c'est pour le bien de delà de
tout le monde
maintenant on est là pourquoi van dyck
et des aides supplémentaires parce que
contrairement à ce qu'ont dit les bars
aujourd'hui tous les petits bacs parce
que les grands établissements avec
beaucoup de personnel le personnel on a
pu le mettre en chômage partiel mais il
faut pas oublier qu'on a des charges qui
courent on a des loyers que la plupart
des gens qui travaillent dans des petits
bars de 35 mètres carrés dans le
quartier bas ils sont ils sont leurs
propres employés ne pas salarié donc
c'est des gens qui n'ont pas et
éligibles au chômage partiel donc là
autour de moi vous avez tous mes
confrères et on a la plupart ils ont
aucun revenu depuis le mois de mars
parce que depuis qu'ils ont ouvert ils
ont réussi à payer à peu près leurs
charges fixes là mais voilà en général
les loyers pas du tout et c'est ça
devient très très compliqué pour tout le
monde